it was here at the sewage plant in east
london where they discovered the polio
virus
a routine inspection for a paralyzing
and fatal disease
last seen in the uk nearly 40 years ago
scientists think the sample they found
was from someone who had received a
so-called live vaccine outside the uk
the vaccine virus does have the
potential to cause paralysis
and if it has mutated and there is
evidence that this vaccine virus is
beginning to mutate but the single
biggest message for individuals is that
they can prevent any risk from that
virus by being fully vaccinated so the
message is to make sure that you and
your family are all up to date for your
routine vaccinations
they expect to find between one and
three samples of polio virus in our
wastewater every year what's different
this time is that the samples they've
found have been several months apart and
are still genetically linked
that suggests community transmission
the bechten sewage plant serves four
million people from chiswick in the west
of the capital to ilford in the east
on average in the uk more than 92
percent of children were vaccinated at
one years old and more than 95 percent
by the age of five
in london though those numbers are below
the national average and could have been
affected by the pandemic we don't want
to panic communities we want them to
understand that the risks are extremely
low but this is a really good moment
just take a moment to check am i are my
children fully up to date with vaccines
if not those vaccines protect us all
from a whole range of communicable
diseases so it's really important that
people go to their gps and make sure
they get their vaccine
they will keep monitoring the wastewater
here and elsewhere in the country at the
same time health workers will be asked
to be vigilant and parents to make sure
their children are up to date with their
vaccinations
the risk is low for now
but
that could change ashish joshi sky news
in east london